Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast, and ahhh.
Yeah.
I'm just checking in on you.
Just checking in to see how your
day's going and give you a quick,
some fucking half hour laughs.
You know,
keep me in your thoughts
and in your prayers.
Yeah,
you're in. I've thought senior in our
prayers. Speaking of that. Houston, Texas.
All right. I got a warning for everybody.
All right. Dan is going to be all
whole
bunch of people making money off
that fucking devastation down there.
Yeah.
All right.
Be careful where you send your money in
because people are going to make videos.
They're going to have your bottom lip
quivering. You're gonna feel bad for them.
And the family fucking dog just makes
sure it's getting to those people.
New York Times put out
lists of shit that's legit.
All right.
Fucking sat there and somebody sent me
something of this woman saying she was a
single mom with two kids. Right.
And uh, I didn't know what the dope,
it's like, do I send,
does this get to you?
Is there a bald hairy back
guy on the other end of this?
So I'm sticking with the Red Cross.
You know,
as I was looking at all those,
I just kept hearing that song.
How do I know that y'all really drown in,
right?
How do I fucking know?
How do I know this is not a scam?
Because people are such pieces of Shit Uk,
they will actually like I want to fuck,
I swear to God they could literally take
it when they find those fucking people,
they find those people. They should,
they should take all the money back,
give it to the victims. And when
the neck, next hurricane comes,
you dropped those fuckers right in the
middle of it, right in the middle of it.
And then when they cry for help,
nobody sends them fucking help.
That's what they should do.
The kinds of pieces of the shit that
would fucking take advantage of people
during a situation like
that. So, um, yeah,
I would donate to the Red Cross.
I'm not going to tell you whether I'm
donating or how much of doting it,
cause I'm sick of fucking people
talking about that. You know,
I like donate in Beijing named Kenny Kenny
Kenny, and not make it about yourself.
Fucking celebrities. Gee, what,
what would they be doing if they weren't
making everything about themselves?
Somebody else's absolute
fucking devastation becomes
an opportunity for them to
show how fucking amazing they are.
Ah,
okay.
Fucking horrific.
Anyways,
I shot nine holes of golf
when I was back east.
It was bag each leads your new family,
Baker's yeast and um, you know,
I love going out and playing golf. I let
him go out there. There's a force him,
everybody's talking Shit, I'm smoking
a cigar. I'm having a good time.
I don't keep score.
I don't give a fuck.
I think I got a 27 combined in the
first two holes. I was just, you know,
yeah, I go, I do like John Daly. Like
I don't, I don't sit there in line,
the Goddamn ball up.
I'm gonna waste everybody's fucking time.
I just walk up and hit it. I take
one practice swing, that's it.
Then I hit the fucking thing.
All right.
I just fucking wind up and you know, I
hit it straight. It just doesn't go for.
So, uh, those guys started giving me tips.
I started listening to him and I just
kept picturing how they swing on TV,
keep that front arm straight, you
know, keep your leg down, you know,
that type of shit. And I ended
up doing all right. You know,
I started breaking eight on holes.
I hate when they go,
you can't score more than an eight on
a whole. It's like, Oh yeah, watch me,
watch me. I'll still be 200 yards from
the hole, taking fucking shot number nine.
All right. That, that is, that
is a fucking myth, my friend.
It has to do with like handicaps or
something. It's just yet another way,
you know,
so there's no cheating or whatever.
It's the biggest fucking cheat and game.
I'm trying to think. Other than like,
you know, business. Um, so anyways,
I got down to the last hole I got,
I got like a seven on the eighth hole
was psych that I broke eight and then on
the last hole was a par four and I
shot a four sank a 30 fucking Florida.
Was that all right? It's all
right. And once again I just,
and then the guy who I was playing with,
the oldest guy in our group was like
looking like it was pushing 60 and he shot
potty pee part for nine holes.
Once again, proving it's not a,
it's not a sport, it's a
game. It's a fucking game.
There's no way it's 60
you know what I mean?
That's like the basketball equivalent is
still being able to dunk when you're 60
you know, and I don't mean
cause you're seven feet tall.
I mean you're like fucking six three he
used to throw it down a little bit back
in the day and then he come back for the
old timers game and you still fucking
dunking.
He is still dropping 30 and then you're
doing it on people like 20 years younger
than you get the fuck out of here.
Um,
but I got to admit I really didn't join
somebody finally explained that why you
tee the ball up high?
I would teed up high and then try
to hit it flush with the club.
I didn't know you kind of swung
underneath it. That was a game changer.
And uh,
that was the,
I dunno my shit as I stink kitten
off the ground on the fairway.
I'm not good at that shit.
But I feel like I could take a couple
of lessons and I could go out there and
not embarrass myself.
MMM.
I only lost,
I only lost one.
I think two balls in nine holes is
pretty good for someone who never fucking
plays my pat myself.
Am I making this about myself?
Am I pulling some fucking move here?
Do you know how much money I donated to
that golf course when I saw all those
white men out there?
I knew I had to do something.
Um,
that's why I created the fun for this
cause named after me with my face on it
because I care. Um, all right,
why does this thing always do this to me?
And then I put,
I typed in the wrong fucking
password, didn't I? And Go
fuck yourself. God dammit.
All right. So yeah, so I, you know,
something, I actually enjoy golf.
I don't have the fucking time
for it, but I do enjoy it. Um,
I also,
uh,
was fucking with my first drum kit I
ever had and it's amazing now that I
actually know how to tune up the drums.
I've got the snare to sound great,
but my fucking base from,
I don't know what was going on with it.
There was like this vibration of
something, no idea what it was.
Maybe, you know, it's one of
those that's an old school.
Slingerland maybe I didn't have the,
uh, you know, he has the clause on it,
which sucks because if you're
gonna do like a quarter turn,
those ones that are on the ground,
you can't fucking do it.
You just got to be a guy. We're just
going to leave those ones alone. But, um,
I got the toms in the snare to sound good.
The bass drums, the last fucking thing.
Then I need to learn how to tune up and
then I have a nice jump off and I think
I'll actually someday actually be
able to tune up a set of drums.
Make him sound about right. That's the
goal anyways. That is the goal, you know,
shooting less than an eight when I go
out and golf every seven years and being
able to a fucking set of drums by the way.
Yeah.
Speaking of that Queens of the stone age,
his new album,
have you listened to it yet? Jesus
Christ. It's fucking amazing.
Listen to it twice. I loved it the first
time. It was even better the second time.
And um, you got, I don't know,
you don't have to check it out.
I'm just saying if you
like fucking great music,
I would definitely check that out.
That's what I've been listening to.
But listening to that and um,
what's his face there?
Where the fuck is my phone?
I can't remember anything anymore.
The fuck is that guy's name?
Yeah.
The Guy who sings a
Mala visa on file.
Yeah.
Uh,
[inaudible] the fuck is his name.
Okay.
Yeah. Jesus Christ. I gotta look up dream
weaver. Weaver. No. So when I got to do,
we'll, we'll, we'll drink Gary. Right?
Gary writes album the fuck's
the name of the album here.
Okay.
It's called the dream. We are no Nada. Is
that the, what's called the dream weaver?
It's under soft rock,
but we don't want,
Andy knew mach one of my new favorite
fucking drummers plays on it and he's
unbelievable. I just wished the
drums are more up in the mix.
Something about like drums in
the fucking seventies they just,
it was like they had a towel
over the entire fucking kid.
They can't hear anything. I'm once again,
the genius of John Bonam to be like,
dude, fuck that. You can't
hear the drums. I wish.
I wish they would remaster that fucking
album and bring Andy's drums up so I can
hear him.
It's fucking incredible.
Incredible player and
everybody sleeps on that album.
Everybody just downloads Dreamweaver and
love is alive. Can't find the is great,
let it out is great blind feeling.
I, if it's a fucking tremendous album and
what he wanted to do evidently was good
to get away from that.
You wanted to have like a fucking get
away from everything being guitar based.
I don't think it's soft rock though.
Some of it is, but not all of it.
It's got some balls.
Right.
Does anybody know what I'm talking about
or who I'm talking about? Probably not.
Oh,
look who's in town this week.
The Boston Red Sox had going to
the fucking New York Yankees.
I got two of my buddies. I'm Ben, 50 bucks
a game for the rest of the year. I'm up,
I'm up a hundred on both
of them. Uh, am I? Yeah,
I think I might put 100 bucks on both
of them. So I'm up 200 bucks total.
So I went to lose a hundred depending
on if the red sox win or lose.
So worst case scenario, I'm down
200 bucks this weekend, I believe.
I think that's what it is, right?
Yeah. That's what the fuck it is. Um,
I'm hoping we've been playing great.
They got swept,
but they played the fucking Indians.
The Indians are on fire.
So we'll see what happens. We're back
up to a five and a half game lead.
I'm loving that. And who knows? With
any luck we'll play the Yankees and the,
and the fucking playoffs hasn't
happened in a long time since 2004.
If I was a giants fan, I would
bring that up all the time. Um, Eh,
you remember when you
champion 15 years ago,
I believe one championship since
then. Yeah. But it doesn't matter.
You can do it that year.
Um, like Yankee Fan.
So you give a shit about 2004 considering
you one in 2009, does it really hurt?
You know what I mean? Exactly.
All right. So, um, all Billie,
no fun. 14 fucking days, no booze.
Once I get this far out in front of it,
once I get this far out in front of it,
I could literally go a year,
um,
you know, I could go the rest of my
fucking life. I just don't choose to,
you know, it's fun. I enjoy it,
but fortunately I don't have that fucking
chemical thing that I already talked
about this because I've started this
podcast like 19 times because I'm never
funny generally. And I'm really not
funny on days when I fucking fly.
Um,
so I'm 14 days in.
I did real good with the Eaton when I was
back east for the first couple of days
in the last two days I've
fucked up, uh, in a major way.
Lots of pizzas and that type of shit.
Um,
I went to my favorite pizza
spot twice and then, uh,
I got this other new spot where I got to
have them free some fucking pizzas for
me and I'm trying to send them out here
through dry ice and all that bullshit.
We'll see what the fuck happens
and we'll see if it happens. Man.
Um,
should I read some at this point?
Is that what I should do?
I think I've talked about everything that
I promote the surf ballroom and clear
Lake Iowa, by the way, it November 5th,
I think is when I'm going to be there.
That's where buddy Holly,
the big Bopper in Ritchie Valens last
plate and be there with Dean del Ray.
And I know I brought this up on Monday,
but I got to keep promoting this fucking
date because they don't do a lot of
standup dates. I'm performing there
because I'm a fan of music and uh,
I always wanted to see that it's like a
museum slash place where you can perform.
So I was like, why don't I just fucking
do both and make a little bit of money?
I get to see this, they get to pay
my respects. You know what I mean?
But I will tell you what,
I am not going to be playing any of that
fucking music that night cause I'm sure
everybody who works there is so God
damn sick of here in a pigsty you eggs.
Do you pick the big seat? I'm
not going to do the team. Um,
I'm going to do the, uh, the movie
version of it to Gary Busey version of it.
You know, just to switch
things up for you. All right.
What am I doing here? Let's,
uh, by the way, it's about
people given Donald Trump shit.
Whenever there's a
fucking natural disaster,
they always give the standing
president shit. Like,
like what is he fucking Zeus as he
supposed to stop it from happening?
You know,
I heard something today that one of the
problems was who's one of the people
that developed in Houston?
They paved over a bunch of wetlands that
would have absorbed a lot of that water,
which then got them talking about
how out here in La that they've,
they've built over land that was just,
it's just going to disintegrate, you know,
whenever we have a big earthquake or
something. Um, cause they were like, well,
what do we do about out here now that
we saw what's going on in Houston,
what should we do out here? I'm like,
there's no fucking hurricanes out here.
But there's always something. The old
earthquakes, Ernie Aaron, when Aaron,
he comes to town, um,
shaking everything up, right?
It's like your absentee father comes
off the road after a fucking three year
bender starts telling you to
make your bed. You're like,
I ain't fucking doing that. Then he
beats you like he doesn't even know you.
That's what an earthquake is like. Um, all
right, let's read some advertising here.
Okay. What do we got here? Oh,
Jesus. These people are new. Sooth.
Do you play sports or workout a lot?
Talk about how sore you can get from
that and now I can trigger injuries.
Why? Why isn't this shit ever edited
under the fucking reading? Oh,
I played golf this weekend. It's now
this week. It's not really a sport.
It's an activity.
I felt fine after.
It's certainly after I fucking sank
that 30 foot. Uh, I do work out.
I fucked up my, uh, my shoulder,
you know? Yeah. It's annoying
that I talk about it long
enough. All right. Lead into
your personal endorsement.
Talk about your personal
experience with your sooth massage.
I don't even know what it is. I haven't,
I haven't. How relaxed you are afterwards,
how easy it was to book, how excited
you are for the next booking, et cetera.
All right. Now, now that
after they wrote me all that,
I guess I'm supposed to look at
this shit before do this, sue.
There's an on demand
massage service. Wow. Jeez.
Oh Jesus. Now. Okay.
Do you get to see what you must
Seuss looks like he is swiping left.
What's going on here? Huh? Sue?
There's an on demand massage service
that delivers a hand selected,
licensed and experienced
massage therapists to you
in the comfort of your own
home hotel or office in
as little as an hour.
Sue's shows up.
I'm sure these people are above board,
but you know there's always a couple
of dirty cops out there that will take
bribe money. Sue, there's
an odd man or you read that.
Um, sue the shows up with everything.
They bring the massage table,
the sheets,
the oil and even music to
drown you out at the end.
Ah, so you can unwind no matter
where you are. I'm sorry,
I'm being really immature. Really
mature. This is all above board.
There's no fucking way we would,
we would do something like that.
You choose to kind of massage
you want from Swedish and sport,
the deep dish and more. They just
fucking lob in this over the Internet.
You can even opt for couples
massages. Alrighty. Here we go.
Get a little fucking freaky,
set the length of your massage and uh,
get to also pick the gender
of your therapists are
right for the homophobes out
there.
Therapists can earn over three and a
half times what they make at as spa while
maintaining incredibly an
incredible schedule flexibility.
That means you can even book a
massage for 10:00 PM on a Wednesday.
This also brings the best
therapists to the PSU.
That network you can book via the
iPhone or Android App on the web.
Soothed is in 50 cities,
including most major US cities and London,
Sydney, Melbourne,
Toronto and Vancouver. Uh,
book a massage.
As soon as today,
our listeners are getting a special offer
that will get you $20 off your first
massage when you use our
code bird download soothe, s,
O, t, h, e or so, the,
um,
in the ios app store or Google play store.
And be sure to use our code bird
to get $20 off your first massage.
Soothed, Spock quality massage
anytime, anywhere. You know,
if they can legalize weed,
why can't they just legalize a hand
job at the end of a fucking massage?
You know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
And just so like the women wouldn't
get all fucking upset because God,
they should have some for women too.
But I'm just saying like, oh my God.
Well it starts with dad
named white yet touching her.
Just have him strap you down like a
fucking La bottomy patient and you know,
and then that's it. Then you
can't touch him. Right. Um,
do you know how much mobile peaceful
the fucking world would be if every guy
started the day with the massage in a
fucking hand job? Do you know much more?
We would listen to you. I mean, and I
don't mean to be a fucking asshole here,
but ladies, we've been asking you to do
this for us for years. And evidently,
you know, after two, three months
into the relationship, it's out. It's,
it's not your pay grade anymore.
Okay.
And what's funny is you can,
you could,
you fucking ladies are going to come
at me like I'm a fucking animal.
Despite the fact,
you know,
this is how guys are wired and
you use it to your advantage.
Whenever you want to
fucking rounded drench,
you fucking let the girls
out a little bit. Right.
You look at somebody just long enough for
them to fucking throw down their card.
You get your drink and then he'd go,
oh,
excuse me that I have a very
important call over this way.
Would that table just opened up? Um, yeah.
And if elected had jobs at Deanna,
massages would be made legal provided
the male was strapped down by the rest.
Yeah.
Um,
can you get to have like
an express massage window
when you don't have time for
the full body massage and you just pull
up like those drive through Starbucks
with like your dick out and some,
some chick just reaches out and
fucking rubs went out. There you go.
Then you fucking drive to work, you know,
cause she's stopping at the yelled at,
at that point,
what the fuck do you care?
You know?
Yeah.
I hope women don't get offended
by this. I am who's kicked? No,
I don't give a shit. If you do or not, but
you know, rather than look down at med,
why don't you understand,
you know,
and try to have empathy and understand
what it is that we're going through.
Oh my God, that would be fucking
tremendous. Drive through fucking massage,
you know what I mean? And then, so you
know, this is what would shut it down.
Some dope would also try to add a coffee
machine to it and eventually someone
would spill coffee on the Dick and that
would be just a fucking lawsuit that
would take the whole industry
down. All right. I don't know.
I'm just brainstorming
here. Alright. [inaudible]
doe
[inaudible] [inaudible] why can't you
rub one out due to [inaudible] me undies.
I'll keep quiet. I won't
shout. If we can be legal.
Why not?
Bad Job.
And when you come in,
you're fucking Soffe shorts out.
Jesus that went off the rails.
A,
you want to look good in your underwear
and be comfortable, right? We'll tell you.
Uh, but that perfect balance
is hard to find. Yeah.
Especially if you're a fat fuck like me.
You know what I mean?
Let's not blame the underwear here.
Let's not blame the victim that's holding
up the weight of my fucking mistakes.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies, man. [inaudible]
dot com and find the best pair
of underwear in the world.
Me undies will be the most comfortable
pair of underwear you will own made from
a sustainably sourced naturally soft
fabric that is three times softer than
cotton for the hi me undies diamond,
same pouch Tommy on these,
I swear to God. Diamond,
same pouch blackout.
Ron Bag cradles your jewels and gives
you stuff to support it needs without
feeling too light.
Are there any male Kardashians?
I bet they'd like something like that.
You know like it's like a Badass old
fucking cell phone cover for your junk.
Ladies will love the soft ecofriendly
fabrics so soft and touchable.
What?
Gross 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
They guaranteed you will it
guarantee you will love your undies.
Fuck did this Gringo or you'll get your
money back right now me and he's having
an exclusive offer for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first
pair and free shipping.
And me undies is so sure you'll
love you their underwear.
They even offer a hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed.
You can order a pair and if you don't
love your first pair of get a full refund,
this is a no brainer. It's a no
brainer. Tries 20% off free shipping,
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
The fuck are you waiting for to get
you 20% off free shipping and there a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
and the best Goddamn fucking softest
underwear you'll ever wear.
Be Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar
this is a limited time offer. Really.
It's an air of all your copy.
So what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of
your life. It changed my life. Did it?
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar
right now. All right, two more. Two more.
Hang in there. Frame bridge, everybody.
Do you ever take a dick pic and
you just lose it and your phone?
Wouldn't it be great if you could
just send it out to get framed?
And he could look up at it every
morning and smile frame bridges.
The easiest way to custom frame your
favorite art and photos without ever
leaving your house with their
simple online ordering process.
You can order a fully customized
piece in minutes. Here's how it works.
Go to frame bridge.com I did this with
my favorite picture of me and my daughter
and I have it right on
my desk and I love it.
Upload your photo from your computer or
directly from your Instagram feed or if
you have a physical, physical item, uh,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging
so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photo online
in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free
help from their talented designers,
the expert team at frame bridge.
We'll custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang. This is perfect
one. There's a birthday coming up,
a little collage action
right there you go.
Uh,
the best part,
but when anything we better have soothed
was actually given out hand jobs.
I'm asking you plus my listeners,
oh, sorry about that. The best part,
instead of hundreds of dollars,
you pay it, the framing store,
their prices start at just 39
bucks and all shipping is free.
Plus don't they just roll it into the
39 bucks plus my listeners will get 15%
off their first order@framebridge.com
when they use my code.
Burn frame bridge even
offers a happiness guarantee.
If for any reason you aren't
100% satisfied with your order,
uh Brad,
they'll make it right.
Give your personal experience using
frame bridge.com I just did the site,
the ease.
It was easy,
it was great and now I look at
that picture of my daughter and I,
I it makes me almost tear up.
It's so beautiful.
Go to frame bridge.com and use Promo
Code burpee you are and you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to frame bridge.com Promo Code
[inaudible] [inaudible] dot com Promo
Code Bar.
You know what sucks is as a heat wave out
here and I always take my daughter for
walks at night or during the dusk or
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
That's a little,
uh,
you know,
daddy daughter thing that we
do. It's awesome. She loves it.
The wind starts coming in
off of the ocean, you know,
blowing on a little tootsies.
She loves it. All right lift.
If you're choosing a ride
sharing company to drive for,
go with the company that treats you better
than the one that rhymes with mover.
It's Lyft. Lyft was the first
to offer in APP tipping.
When you drive for lit man,
you get to keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers of pay had been paid over 200
million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost
instantly set up waiting for weeks.
Lyft is even taking the guesswork
out of pickups. Where is he?
The new APP device uses color coding
to help passages find their drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips. You want to earn more money,
drive more, or drive more. It's never
been easier to give yourself a race.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers being happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft
rides get a perfect five star rating.
Go to lift.com/burger today and you
can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/bar
lyft.com/burr or limited time
only terms do apply. All right.
I'm laying on the floor
and my fucking back.
I'm trying to fix that
fucking crib downstairs.
Ugh.
So the thing, once your kid just gets
over like fucking seven, eight months,
you know, it's just like you picking
up this sack of potatoes. You don't,
you didn't have a squat down to do it
right? You bend at the waist, right?
Blowing out your lower back
is the fucking worst. Um,
all right,
what the hell did I want to talk about?
Was there anything to talk about beyond
okay,
what everybody else is talking about?
I try to stay outside of all of that.
You know what I mean? Everybody's
like, you know, talking about it,
raining down in Houston, right.
The hurricane and all of that shit.
Am I going to be yet another file?
I guess I already did.
Yeah.
But I did it in a way. I actually told
you to watch out for these fucking scams.
How do,
right,
you always got to ask that because I
gave a bunch of money to that wounded
warriors thing and then I got all this
information that it was a fucking scam.
I don't know if it is a not, but there
was enough fucking articles that it was,
and it made me nervous that allegedly
that's what they were doing over there.
And that fucking turned
me off to charities that,
that they could possibly be
somebody out. And then, you know,
watching that pink lady in the NFL.
So make sure you fucking money,
you know,
gets to the people speaking in which
Ron White is doing a gig out in Austin,
Texas.
Um,
he's going out with some
other comedians in all,
all the proceeds are going
to be going to, uh, you know,
help out the people there in Houston.
Um, so there's a good one you can go to.
All right. I wasn't able to
make the GIG and I said, well,
who should I make the checkout
to? He said, Red Cross. All right.
So then I looked it up. Is the Red
Cross? I know, I saw him on mash.
Are they reputable? And they checked
out. They are reputable. So there you go.
All right. And with that, I am
completely out of shit to talk about.
I don't know what I've talked about cause
I've started this fucking podcast 15
fucking times. I have no
goddamn idea. You know,
so I don't know what to tell you people
other than this is the end of this
podcast right here.
But even though it is the end,
I'm going to continue to talk for another
fucking two minutes and three seconds.
Contractually obligated to do
a half hour here. All right,
there you go. You want to get
fucking first world problem.
I got bumped up to first
class, right? And, uh,
they sat me in the last
row right by the bulkhead,
so my fucking seat didn't
recline, you know, and that,
ladies and gentlemen is a classic example
of Code Lotion. Remember Cold Lotion?
I'm bringing it back.
Cold Lotion,
classic example of fucking cold lotion.
If you don't know what it means,
it's in the urban dictionary.
It's basically somebody gives
you something nice, but it
fucking sucks. It's like,
hey, somebody says, well, I'm puts it,
you know, your back's all dried out.
Your wife goes, Hey, can you put some
lotion on your back? You Go, absolutely.
She goes, thank you sweetie. But you know,
warming up in your hands yet you just slap
it right on her back. She's like, Nah.
Right, right there as some fucking cold
lotion. You get bumped up to first class,
you're in the last row. You seats
up against the bulkhead. See,
you can't fucking lean back.
Cold fucking lotion.
But I'll tell you what I watched.
Uh, I watched three movies,
two and a half movies. I watched, um,
founder starring Michael Keaton about,
uh,
how the whole Mcdonald's franchise
came about. And it was fantastic.
Movie, loved it. Then I
watched the original alien,
which totally holds up
other than their computers,
cause what's fucking hilarious
as they're flying through space,
doing shit we still can't do today.
But like the computers, you know,
it looks like fucking war games.
I know it's 1979 technology.
MMM. But everything about
movie was fucking awesome.
And Sigourney weaver was fucking bad ass
and everybody should have listened to
her. That fucking, I can't
say what happens. You know,
they didn't listen to her. Um,
she falls,
she wanted to follow protocol.
And then I watched the beginning of
chips because I wanted to see, uh,
I wanted to see the motorcycles. You
know, it's a couple of two counties.
That was cool. And then the plane
landed and then that was fucking it.
That was it. But I saw two good moods.
I didn't watch enough for chips to know.
You know, all I wanted to see is where
Erik Estrada was going to be in it. Right.
And John Baker, Larry Wilcox, you
know, they had to be in there. Right.
And I bet the sarge was there.
Baby Grossman. What about Berry?
You know,
you know what they should've done.
They should've put fucking
what's her face in them? Uh,
Caitlyn Jenner. Bruce Jenner did a
couple of seasons on that fucking thing.
Ben
[inaudible].
Fuck, I made it 30 minutes. There you
go. That's your podcast for this week.
I apologize. I know this one stunk. I
just, I suck when I'm on. I'm on a plane.
You know what I mean? I just, I don't
know what the fuck it is. I just, uh,
it just never seems to work out for me.
A separate bottle,
breathing dirty air, not
being able to recline my seat.
I have no idea. All right.
That's it. That's the podcast. Thank
you everybody for, uh, for listening.
Enjoy the music. And now
we're going to play some, uh,
classic Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday.
Whatever the fuck I call this thing.
Um, enjoy the greatest hits. All right.
That's it. Have a great
weekend. You can't, and uh,
I'll talk to you later.
Do you ever get nostalgic for the
90s? If so, what part of the 19th.
Can you have your podcast guy used?
The friends theme song
for the Thursday podcast.
That's a question mark yet or
anything awesome from the 90s.
Uh,
[inaudible]
I dunno, I have the, have the
cock blocks all been defined,
like the different kind of cock blocks.
I don't know if there's this
names for them, but I got a new,
I've got a new cock
block for you. Uh, this,
this cock block is very
special and a very obvious one.
And I think like this
happens all the time,
but for some reason I've never heard
anybody name it. So I'm, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna kick off the creative process.
I call this guy the announcer.
That's the,
uh,
that's, that's the name of this cock
block. This is what happened to me.
I was, I did a Gig in Jersey
and at the end of the night,
these two girls who waited to be at the
back of the line came up and they said,
hey, you want to go out and
get banana pancakes? You know,
making a reference to my joke saying
if I wanted to go out and hang out with
both of them. Right. And the
second day said it, I was like,
Holy Shit, here's a fucking,
here's something I never had.
Here's a two on one and I can't
fucking do it cause I'm with Nia.
Who's kidding?
Oh cool.
Not Cause I'm with Nia is
because everyone's got a
cell phone fucking camera.
And I get caught.
Honesty. Um, no, I couldn't deal
with the guilt. Um, uh, but I got it.
I'll be honest with you, and I
would say this, if Nia was here,
if two fucking tens came up to me and
said, let's do this. I, I, you know,
yeah, fuck it. Let's do it. I
never did it. You know, fuck it.
So anyways, so they said,
hey, you want to get a,
you want to go on and get bananas
and pancakes or something like that.
And then this fucking guy like 10
feet arrayed wages, it goes like, oh,
let's go. You know, those guys,
like if a girl just comes up to
you, just like, you know, you know,
I've always loved guys in
green shirts and your thinking,
raise your thinking like, holy
fuck, this is going to happen.
There's some other guy
like five. Yeah. Hey
and just makes the whole file the
whole fucking room. Look over at you.
The fucking announcer.
Fucking cock block mother fucker.
You know who would do that?
Yeah.
If I was standing there and I heard
two girls said to a guy and be like,
God damn,
it's going down right side of my mouth.
That blocky motherfucker I wouldn't be on.
Yeah.
Yes.
I mean why would you do that?
The fucking announcer. And if you
have a friend like that, all right.
The only way you can still hang out
with them is it. If he goes out,
if you guys are going
out trying to meet women,
he has to wear one of those old ABC
bright yellow Monday night football sport
coats.
Okay.
And if the girls, why is he wearing
that? You'll see. You'll see.
Okay.
And that'll be the, that would be
the funniest fucking thing ever.
Like if somehow if he couldn't figure
out the joke and he just thought the coat
look good and just the whole
night you just saw him.
Anytime you heard in the,
you know, 10 feet away,
what's this all about?
Hey,
just look over and you'd see this guy
dressed like Howard Cosell and you'd be
like, oh, that's the
announcer. He's the, he's the,
he's the guy he can cock block from.
Like, he's almost like a sniper.
If he wasn't so fucking loud, he's at
the same distance as a fucking marksman,
but he kills it with, uh,
with loudness. Oh my God.
Did that guy fucking annoy me?
Hey Mia, come here. Come here.
She just came and shaking her head.
You are loud.
What I am beyond,
come on over here.
I was just telling that story with
that Guy Cock blocked me with those two
chicks out in a Jersey where they
would just go with cock blocked you.
I told you this story.
No,
but you making it seem like you were
going to do something and no, no,
I wasn't going to do something.
This is the thing,
but I just admitted general cock blocking.
Yeah, but this is what I did admit.
If they were both tens, I would've,
I would've, I would've done it.
I never had a fuck two on one and you
know someone would you be that mad if they
were both smoking hot and
the cell phone video got out?
The video is even need to get
out when you got the announcer.
They the guy he just literally goes like,
yeah,
we'd like to get bananas and
Pancakes with Yoni Southern
[inaudible]
nothing. You're a jerk. Why
am I a jerk? So pajamas. Huh?
You are talking about cock
blocking and two, one one.
So what kind of podcast is this
turning into? You know what,
it's turning into a very honest podcast.
I was very honest.
I said this is good for you. This
is the thing I said I couldn't, uh,
I couldn't deal with the
guilt unless if they, if,
unless they were both Ted's, if they're
both fucking tends, give me a break.
Let me tell you something.
If you hooked up with Brad Pitt,
there's only so mad I could get.
Oh, it's fucking Brad Pitt. Okay.
Yeah. Good to know. Okay, well you
know what that would, that if I just,
if I just said some generic,
what a good looking guy.
If I just said some generic good looking
guy and you, and you just said that,
that would have scared me.
But the way you just acted like
you had Brad Pitt's phone number.
That doesn't scare me. Oh
really? Okay. It's going down.
And what if it's the like the regular
guy version of Brad Pitt. Is that okay?
Like he's just as good if you want to go
live out on the street and get the fuck
out of this house. Absolutely. But you're
allowed to have some sort of crazy two.
One one. Yes. That's bullshit. No it
isn't. It is. If you just, you know,
cause you're thinking on it on like, like
a, a very basic level. But if you really,
but if you really think about it, just
think about it. It makes sense. Bill,
you're not going to try to mind fuck me
into thinking that it's okay for you to
have some sort of two on one
and I can, that's not, no,
it's not going down like that.
Yeah. But God, women are beautiful.
Where we lust after.
You would totally make sense.
You guys find like Dick's or weird.
They're gross. It's all hanging out there.
It's disgusting. You don't want
that. You know nothing about you.
You don't want that,
which has been proven time and time
and again and your stand up and in your
podcast. But that's a, that's another
discussion. You know what you,
you just set yourself up like you're
going to make some huge point and then you
just tapped out. You know nothing
about women but it doesn't,
but that's just another discussion and
I just don't want even to get into that.
So now what? You just gave me the face.
What are you doing today? Lazy. Huh?
What do you mean it?
Lazy Nini. Kubrick? Yeah.
I just filled my short film
over the weekend. Screw you.
I'm working hard while you're in here in
your pajamas talking about two on ones.
Yeah. Well I have to do an hour's worth
of shit here. I'm coming up on it,
fill it up with whatever,
an hour and two minutes,
an hour to minutes. Have you done
your a dear viewer emails yet? Yeah,
I did.
You are listening or emails.
You did that already cause
you want to chime in? I Dunno.
What do you guys already did it? What
about overrated? Underrated. Didn't do it.
They didn't have any this
week. Oh, okay. Look at you.
I think you're a fan of
this podcast. No, I'm not.
Listen, it didn't go down. All right,
but I'm telling you right now,
Nia, if two tens come up to me,
it's going down. Okay. All right. Well
just be prepared for the retaliation
game set match. Really?
You're going to deny me that?
Can I just buy you some
stuff? Wow. Really? Yes.
Really?
Not some sort of fucking basketball
wife that can be placated with material
things to a point. Yeah, exactly. Okay.
If I'm going to be fucking honest here,
come on. This gotta be something
that I can buy. You know something.
This should be our Valentine's
Day. All right. For the guy,
the Guy Valentine's Day,
this is what Valentine's Day should be
every year is the guy gets a two on one
and then you get some nice stuff.
Well why can't I have it too on one?
Because you don't like that. What
do you mean? What do you know?
Women don't like sex?
You don't find like
when you guys fantasize,
you think about the guys in your life.
You don't think about other things.
Um, come on Nia. Just one. Just give
me one. You get one and I get one.
No you don't. You don't because you
don't want one. What do you mean?
I don't want you just being childish. No
I'm not. Yeah, you are. You do. You see,
see you think you think
you want to hook up with,
with Jake Gyllenhaal in a bread face,
whatever the fuck his name is. Brad Pitt.
Brad thread. Face pit. You
just think you do. See,
you know what to think about me is,
is like you have to hook
up with somebody famous.
I'm actually just regular people. See
I'm down to earth with this shit. See,
that's what I'm saying. You like stuff
you like shiny, shiny things. Oh,
this is a deal. I get a two
on one and you, you get some,
some cracked up face old man
in Vegas like Robert Redford.
Like I used to be good looking
when Nixon was in office. No, no,
that's not how negotiating works.
Now you've got to come with
something else here. No,
I think we should both get an
equal opportunity thing going on.
This isn't an equal relationship. Why?
Why is it not an equal relationship?
Cause I wanted to,
I could pin you down to the ground right
now and tickle you until you passed out.
And there's not a fucking
thing you can do about it.
What did that has nothing to do with
anything. That's how the world works in.
Yeah. Why do you think America's
on top? Because we're right.
Well because we could. Oh, because?
Because we can blow you up more times.
So it's your,
your physical presence.
That's what makes it like an
unequal relationship. Yeah.
Cause I can beat you down.
Well maybe you're physically stronger,
but I'm mentally stronger than yeah.
Oh
snap. I'm smarter than you. Yeah.
So whatever physical power.
Let me ask you this.
What do you have are trumped
by my mental fucking Goliath.
Notice those suck on that red.
Why do you think you're smarter
than me? Oh, that was good though.
You got a good one in a, now you're
storming off. I taught you. Well
[inaudible] man on needs of
[inaudible] all the way.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and this is the Monday
morning podcasts for Monday,
August 31st, 2009 and I am recording
this one from Stockholm, Sweden.
That's right. I'm a big shot
international traveler. You know,
not bad for some bomber. Used to work in
a warehouse. Stockholm, Sweden, people.
Um, I've been here for a week and uh,
it has been absolutely incredible.
I'm not going to lie to you.
It's one of the most beautiful cities
I've ever been to and has some of the most
beautiful people I've ever seen.
And I'm not gonna lie to you.
I got to go with the Adolf
Hitler on this one. A,
these are some good luck in sons of
bitches out here, you know? I mean,
I don't think that's an excuse to go
out and try to eliminate all the other
races of people.
He took it a little far,
but I can definitely see what
he was enamored with. Like,
I'm not even kidding you like,
like these are some of the most,
even like the guys,
like I was walking down the street,
my girl and go look at that fucking guy.
Would you look at them?
How was that guy? Not famous stack.
I would be Brad Pitt and our country.
Look at them even. They are all people
are good looking. You know what?
All the younger dudes,
they all look like a, um,
who's that fucking dude with the,
with the Paul Mccartney haircut that
all the girls are screaming about.
He's got those Jim Breuer eyes,
you know,
those glassy eyes and he's got the
fuck and a Paul McCartney haircut.
I think it was in one of those
high school musical. I Dunno,
they all fucking look like
that except it's blonde and uh,
and I dunno. And then,
then the older guys,
they all look like fucking
like the bad guy in,
in a Mel Gibson 1980s movie,
you know,
something like that. And then the women
are just absolutely fucking ridiculous.
I saw this girl, uh, like, I
haven't even, you know, you,
when you walked down the
street with your girlfriend,
you try to like subtly look at women.
I was not doing that,
had absolutely no respect for,
I was just going, Jesus Christ,
and then she, she wouldn't even
punch me, but it was in the states.
She would fucking punch you. But here
she was just like, was, was that a VJ?
You know, it was that, uh, you
know, that just fucking gorgeous.
And I'm sitting there, I've
never felt like I had, uh,
that I was compromised genetically
until I came to a Stockholm, Sweden
and I was really starting
to get a complex.
But yesterday I took the subway or the,
the on the ground as they call it.
Do you want to find the underground?
Uh, they don't talk like that,
but that's my hacky foreign accent.
Um,
and I took the subway out of Stockholm,
Sweden, and I went to some of the, like,
it was almost like I got on the train
and I went up to the Bronx or like out to
queens.
And that's evidently where they
keep all their ugly people and a,
yeah, all of a sudden I felt
like I was in revere, you know,
or Medford. So there's
definitely some, uh,
there's definitely some struggling
people here. You know what,
you know what it looks like.
Like all his stock home looks like Soho
in New York where everyone's really
trendy,
really fashionably dressed and just
fucking ridiculously good looking.
And uh, you know, like I said,
I've never felt like, uh,
I've never felt like I should be
sleeping under a bridge before,
until I came out here.
But anyways,
so with that, I had one
show this weekend, um,
on the 29th, I was
working the, uh, I dunno,
some fucking theater, I forget
the name of it, but, uh,
I was all nervous because everybody over
here, even though they're bilingual,
you know, they, they fractions
fashion, fashion when they're
walking around, right?
So the comedians going on in front of
me are all up there, gone out loud,
shouting, shouting louder. Right. And
I'm fucking sitting back there going,
I don't think these people are going
to get what the fuck I'm talking about.
So fortunately I was smart and I,
uh,
I went up the night before my,
my theater Gig is what I did.
I went up the night before
and I kinda got all that,
like nervousness out and I was able to
figure out just a couple of things to
switch up.
Like I made a reference to kickball.
If you guys saw my tonight show set,
I did where I talk about the bankers
striking out playing kickball.
They don't know kickball over
here. So one of the other, uh,
comedians told me switch
it to soccer. I said, okay.
And just little adjustments like that.
So I kind of had an okay set,
um, Thursday, but I was really on my
fucking heels. I really felt like a freak.
Um, but then Friday came
along and um, I dunno, it was,
the theater wasn't packed.
It was sort of like maybe like half full.
So I have this weird psychological
thing where if a room is in full,
I don't feel nervous, but if
it's full, I feel nervous.
And it has nothing to do with numbers.
If you had a room that only held like
40 people and there was 40 people in
there,
I would feel a pressure to kill.
But if you stuck me in a theater
at that held like, you know,
700 people and there was
only 400 people there,
I would feel like I was
in this little last crowd.
So that's basically what happened.
And I went out and I had a great time,
destroyed, got a standing
ovation in the end and I was,
I can't even tell you how fucking
relieved I was because you know,
it took me 16 hours to get here from La.
So you really don't want to bomb.
And um,
one of the goals of coming over here was
to fucking destroy so that I can start
build building like a following
over here. Because, you know,
like most people,
I've always wanted to come to Europe
and see all this stuff over here,
but it be even better if I could come
over and make a little bit of money.
So that's Kinda my goal, you
know, going to start, you know,
getting a following over
here and I'll fly over here,
I'll make some kronas here in Sweden,
and then I'll go fucking blow,
blow it all in Italy or fucking
that Paris, if some shit,
why the fuck not right? Come over
here, drink like Ernest Hemingway,
act like I'm an actual fucking artists
rather than someone who curses every
other word. But, um, so this
is the funny part, right?
So I killed and everything was
great and I felt fantastic.
And then the next night, you know,
they go, well, hey, you know,
we're having this comedy festival,
this is big theater show.
It's going to be sold out even more
people who came out to your show,
do you want to do it? And
I said, yeah, fuck it.
I'll do it because I'll get
in front of more people.
Maybe they'll come to my show. And, uh,
like a fucking typical comic.
I couldn't just leave.
I couldn't leave on a high note. I had
to go for one more and I went up and a,
I only did okay.
Saturday night I came out
a little too cocky and, um,
I think I kinda came off like an ass.
I didn't suck, but it wasn't great.
But,
um,
I know it wasn't great because when
I got off one of the people was like,
how did you feel about that?
That's like, that's when, you
know, it could have been better.
It when they don't say great
job, when somebody says,
how did you feel about that?
Um, I dunno, I'm probably making a bigger
deal out of it than it was. But, uh,
but anyways, it was a, a,
it was a big success over
here and I really miss my
dog and I'm ready to go back.
I got one more day over
here today. And, um,
I actually went to a museum yesterday
and they have this, this, uh,
I can't explain what the fuck it
is basically in the 16 hundreds.
It's kind of a funny story. The, uh,
the king over here commissioned this big
battle ship to be built and it actually
had two gun decks. I think back in
the day. They only usually had one,
but they built two gun decks.
Literally. I like fuck.
And I counted when I want to
look at it like they had like,
like 20 some odd cannons on both sides.
It was absolutely huge.
The carvings and the woodworking in the
back of the ship. And you know, like the,
the little windows where you open up,
where you stick to the cannons out.
They had like these, these uh,
lion's heads carved in. I know,
I guess it was something
else to intimidate the enemy.
Like the fucking Canon's weren't enough.
You know,
I thought the 20 candidates were bad dude,
but they got a fucking,
they got a fake lion head and it doesn't
look happy, you know, so anyways,
so they commission have this ship
built so they build the fucking thing.
Everybody piles on the Goddamn thing.
They got the guns out and all this shit,
you know,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
I can go out in the bay.
So like a couple thousand people watch
and fucking sick.
Then I even got to use it.
It'd be like if you bought a brand new
car and you know you come home, do a,
what's it got got three 51 queen don't
fucking do a burnout and he just fucking
with like eight miles on the car,
you
wrap it around a pole.
And not only do you wrap it around a pole,
all your friends fucking watch.
And even though they're your friends,
you know they're fucking secretly happy
because they can't be happy for you
because you have a better car, which
means you're going to get better pussy.
So it's just in their DNA,
right?
So they fucking take this boat out
there and they say a squall came.
I didn't look up to see what a squall was.
Is that some sort of a storm?
Is it a gust of wind?
I know it isn't a rogue wave.
That's one of the worst
lines ever in a movie.
Did you guys ever see perfect storm?
A rogue wave evidently is like this
mini tidal wave that just comes out of
fucking nowhere. And a lot of times
it washes people off the boat. So,
um, most people are, you know,
they're not out to see like me.
So you have no idea what the fuck it was.
So if you just showed a
rogue wave and a movie,
if the seas were kind of calm and all
of a sudden this big wave out of fucking
nowhere, just washed a couple
people overboard, you, you,
you would've been like me sitting
in the movie theater going,
what the fuck was that?
So they literally had to have
mark Wahlberg's character's
scream out rogue wave
as it comes in. Do you remember
that? Who would yell that out?
You know, what'd you yell
get, you know, get down or
whatever the fuck you'd, you'd,
you'd yell, Fuck Dude,
that's what you'd yell.
You wouldn't yell.
Like if someone pulled a gun on you and,
and started shooting at you,
you, you'd be screaming,
no running down the alley. You
wouldn't be like, you know, 38 special
anyways, let me fucking, let me,
let me plow ahead here. All right,
so they send the ship out.
Everybody's standing on the shore.
Is everybody's all proud? Oh, do y'all
look at this size as they bought?
Look at these ions heads. Yeah. Right.
And the fucking thing is some
sort of squall hits it. Then they,
I don't know what happened.
It started to right itself
and then another one hit
it and it just fucking went
down. And when you got two decks
of guns, you go down quick,
like 50 people fucking drowned.
It was just a nightmare.
And evidently they had some sort of
stones at the bottom of the boat,
but they didn't have enough.
I think that's to make it
sort of sit in the water.
You don't really came across. It kind of
came across like a, what Chrysler said,
this Zukie Samurai was where it said a
tipped over at like two miles an hour
because of its center of gravity,
which evidently was a total fucking lie.
They just wanted to sell more jeeps.
But I think that that's
basically what happened.
They built this big grand
fucking boat and uh,
oh yeah, they had, they had
trials trying to figure out,
everybody was blaming each person.
But Anyway,
so the motherfuckers sinks to the bottom
of the bay and over time people kind of
forgot where the fuck it was.
And uh,
it stayed down there for 333 years
before they, they, they brought up,
somebody found it,
they brought it back up and it was
in pristine fucking condition. Jesus,
this is a long way to go. And me and my
girl went to the museum and we saw it.
I'm going to tell you,
it's one of the most amazing
fuck it things I've ever seen.
And which is funny because if you tell
anybody in Sweden that you're going to go
see it, they just laugh at
you. Because I guess his kids,
they always get dragged there and they
have to do book reports on it and they
fucking hate the thing. It's the typical
thing. Think about where you live.
Think about what the
tourist attractions are.
You never go to the tourist
attractions in your own town. Okay.
There's just something in human
beings DNA where you're like, dude,
I'm not standing in line in
my own fucking town. You know?
It's like when I lived in New York,
I never went to the statue of Liberty
or the empire state building unless some
friend of mine came to town
and they wanted to go and
I hated every second of it.
You know, that's basically the deal.
But if you ever go to Stockholm, Sweden,
I'm telling you, you have to
go. You gotta go, you know,
you got to go check it out if you're
into that type of shit. It was,
it was unbelievable.
I don't read a lot of this stuff either.
I was getting like sleepy when
I start reading the plaques.
I just like looking at the shit and the
little fucking boots that they have.
People were so small back then,
you know?
I always wondered if I could go
back in time, like the size I am,
if I would be like the
toughest guy in town, you know?
Especially if you've mentioned,
if you took like Jujitsu classes and
all the latest fucking fighting styles,
what a Goddamn Badass you
are. You'd be, you know,
now wait a minute.
They had like those fucking spiky
balls that were at the end of the chains.
All right.
Do I sound dumb enough to make this an
official fucking podcast? All right,
let's get on with the
podcast. Um, Oh, before I do,
I just want to thank everybody who
came out to my, uh, to my show at,
at rival arrive out of the
whoever the fuck you said. Um,
I had a great time and it was an absolute
thrill to go onto the other side of
the planet and actually have
people know who the fuck I was.
I haven't brought up my dog and somebody
in the crowd yelled out Cleo that there
was actually people who,
uh, listen to the podcast,
which was really awesome and fucking scary
all at the same time. I was like, yeah,
I got a dog recently and somebody
yelled out, cleo. I was like, yeah,
it was really, uh, you know, you'll
papers please. Yeah. You know,
there was that in somebody else was like,
what is that to do out here?
What should I be doing out here?
And some in the crowd fucking yelled out,
come to my house,
we'll have a party.
I'm not even exaggerating.
That's what it fucking sounded like.
And I wanted to record that guy and my
cell phone and have that as my outgoing
message that if you called me and it
went directly to my, my outgoing message,
that's what would come up rather
than, hey, this is bill. Uh, you know,
leave a message. You can't,
you know, it was actually,
it would be him just going come
to my house. We'll have a party
boot.
All right, let's plow ahead here. Oh,
somebody actually informed me that
last week was the first time, uh,
in the history of my podcast,
I did an entire podcast without
using the word content. Um,
I don't know what that says
about that person, but a,
they're definitely into the podcast.
Okay. Um, let's move on here.
Getting on with the podcast. Uh, this is,
somebody sent me a really good
email about last week when I was,
I was going off on how,
um,
somebody had made fun of Ringo Starr
and said something to the effect of,
you know,
cause Ringo said that he wasn't going
to be signing anymore anything anymore
after like October, basically after
50 years of signing autograph,
the guys approaching 70 years of age,
his wrist is going to fall off.
He's probably going to die within the next
decade. Right. That's still a good run.
He wants to go do some shit.
So of course all the fans get
pissed and someone's like, you know,
we told us he wouldn't be famous.
And I was saying that that
was really a, a, an arrogant.
Did somebody just knock on the fucking
wall telling me to shut up on tissue
yelling? Yeah. Um, oh, go fuck
yourself. I'm doing a podcast. Um,
anyways, so I thought that that was
just an arrogant statement. Like,
like the fans,
like if it wasn't for the fans, he
wouldn't be famous. It's like, yeah,
totally discounting the man's talent.
He's considered one of the
greatest drummers of all time.
He inspired an entire
generation to play drums. Um,
I dunno.
So anyway,
I can't really even explain my point of
view because so much so many of my point
of views are just spur spur of
the moment, you know. So anyways,
the guy writes 'em on your last podcast,
you were talking about how the fans
don't make someone who they are.
The fans in this guy says,
the fans don't make someone talented.
You're right about that.
But without the fans,
all the talent in the
world doesn't mean Shit.
How many talented performers have faded
away because they failed to find an
audience?
How many Notel and hacks hacks are
making a living in entertainment in the
entertainment industry just because
they somehow managed to get a bunch of
mindless fucktard's to buy their crap.
Um,
uh, yeah, I mean you know some,
I understand what you say in
there and he brings up this,
this great point of how, uh, that that
show carnival or Carney val, however, the,
however the hell you said it was
on HBO and he said to this day,
it's probably the second best show
they've ever had behind the wire but they
cancel the show up to two seasons claiming
that the DVD sales weren't sufficient
to justify the amount of money they
were spending on making the show.
Um,
yet stale shit like 24 which is retelling
the same fucking story every goddamn
years and its eighth season.
Just being talented isn't what keeps
entertainers employed. The fans do.
Okay. Now that's actually, that's
kind of a different argument.
Okay. I was saying that fans are not
the reason Ringo Starr is famous.
If you wanted to say like if it wasn't
for the songwriting ability of Paul
Mccartney and John Lennon, Ringo Starr
might've ended up washing dishes,
I would go with that.
I would definitely go with that.
All right. And I can definitely
see that aspect of it.
But to sit there and, and like put
it this way, if it wasn't for ACDC,
I wouldn't have had a life
in my teenage years. Okay.
And at no unknown level do I feel like
Angus and Malcolm should thank me for
back in black for the success of back
black. They made a fucking killer album,
you know,
and they worked their asses off
on it and it was so fucking good.
My ears couldn't ignore it.
All right. I'm not part,
I wasn't part of this group of
people who sat there and said,
you know what we're going to do today?
We're going to make ACDC
famous and God dammit,
those sons of bitches better appreciate
us because if it isn't, well,
if it wasn't for us,
did back in black album would suck.
I guess if we didn't buy it, they
would have disappeared into obscurity.
But like I just give ACDC more
credit because they're an organized
group of people creating something
and I'm just a fucking jackass walking
around. I don't know. I don't look at
it that way, but I definitely see, yeah,
if people don't listen to your shit,
um,
then you don't sell any of it then then
yeah, your career is over. Absolutely.
But I don't feel that buying the
shit is in the control of the fans.
I think the artists make something so
great. You have to buy it, you know?
And as far as like a TV show,
I hate this expression because I don't
hunt, but I'm going to use it anyways.
As far as a TV show goes, that's
an entirely different animal, man.
I hate when people say that,
but it kind of fits here.
A TV show is different because
what you're doing there is your,
you're trying to go like
you're commercially fishing.
You don't give a fuck you,
you're trying to grab as
many people as you can.
Okay.
As opposed to just doing what you do.
I can't explain it.
Having a TV show goes beyond doing
what you do and if they like, you know,
build it, they will come.
It goes beyond that because,
you know, just because they weren't
selling enough DVDs, that's,
is that really a fan thing or is that
the cons in the industry who have this,
this corporate mentality where every
quarter they have to make more money?
You know what I mean?
So it causes them to do
things after only two seasons.
I mean, I don't know. I'm not trying
to belittle people who are fans.
I don't think that artists should
take their fans for granted,
but I don't feel as a fan of
all the people I'm a fan of.
I don't feel like they
owe their success to me.
And if they don't want to sign something,
I'm fine with that.
Does that make me fucking weird? I don't
think Ringo Starr 70 fucking years old.
What, what the, what
more is he going to say?
How many more pairs of tits
connect guy sign? All right.
It's probably got diarrhea
every other Thursday. I mean,
can the guy fucking live his life? I
don't know. All right, let's, uh, let's,
let's move on here. All right.
You know what I mean? Like,
I just went to Stockholm,
Sweden, I, I just said thanks to
every, all the fans you came out.
I don't take them for granted.
You know,
I was fucking kissing babies and
shaking hands at the end of my show.
But I've got to admit,
if I'm coming over here at 70 I want to
be wheeled back to my hotel and drink
some tea.
And that wouldn't mean that
I'm taking them for granted.
It just means I'm fucking
old and I'm tired.
Okay.
Do you know how many autographs
Ringo is? Probably, you know,
I've already been through this. He
gets no credit. 50 years of autographs.
It's not enough. And then people are
going to take credit for his success.
I just thought that that was a
little out of line. All right.
That's all I'm fucking trying to say
there. You know, and like I said,
having said that,
I will be kissing babies and sell it,
signing DVDs and taking pictures with
awful fucking digital cameras that for
some reason take like he just don't shoot.
You know,
you've got to hold the button
down for like 19 minutes and,
and you gotta is it the 18th flash or the
19th flash where I can finally stopped
smiling. Um, alright.
Plowing ahead. Uh, Bill. Uh,
so something kind of ridiculous happened
to me the other day and you're the only
person who I think might appreciate
my point of view on the matter. Okay.
So this is really good looking lady,
uh,
that works at the sandwich shop
around the corner from my job.
So I've been going there for like a
year now and I've always wanted to say
something to her but never did because
either the place was too busy at the time
or I just pushed it out,
usually the ladder.
So the other day I finally man up and
decide to say something and it went a
little something like this. I go
in after two, so it's not as busy.
I place my order, she makes me a
rep, she hands me a wrap and I say,
excuse me.
Uh,
I've been coming in here for a while and
I've always wanted to introduce myself
and before I can even get the words out,
her smiling expression turns blank,
her lip seal tight and she kind of
looks up at her eyebrows with that.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Look all over face.
I can only equate a shit. I just hit
the wrong button on my computer. Um,
he goes, I can only equate the
look to an a to an employee,
what an employee might have when they're
done with their work for the week and
on Friday evening, right as they feel
like they're going to get out of there,
the boss comes and drops another hour's
worth of paperwork on their desk.
They can't say anything, but you know,
they're thinking, you fucking prick.
So what I ended up saying after
I get this look from this chick,
is this is basically what the
guy says. He said, excuse me,
I've been coming in here for a while and
I've always wanted to introduce myself.
You know what? Fuck it. Never mind.
And he goes, I turned around.
I just walked out. All right.
And he goes, now, here's my issue,
dude. We've all been there. All right,
we've all fucking been there. Um, all
right. So he goes, now here's my issue.
It's not that I was rejected.
Big Deal. That should happens
all the time, right? Uh,
that's like an ongoing theme in an adult
life and I've learned to live with it.
Jesus do don't jump off a
cliff here. Um, he goes,
my problem is that's success sis as a
society, I can't even talk Acessa society.
The,
my problem is society dictates that the
guy should approach the girl and all the
girl really needs to do is look pretty,
throw a few signals and wait for
dudes to start clamoring like morons.
Is it fair? No. But then again,
it's really not a big deal.
It's one of the situations
you grow accustomed to.
But if that is the case and if
all women have to do is be pretty,
then say yes or go fuck yourself.
Could they at least wait 30 seconds
for me to say whatever, retarded shit,
whatever. Retarded Shit I'm
thinking before they shoot me down.
All she has to do is wait a
minute and say, no thank you.
But instead I get cut off
by Stinkeye mid sentence.
Should I have told her to go fuck herself?
What are your thoughts on this sort of
shit? Your true and loyal fan? Bobo.
The douchebag. Alright. Um,
what am I failings on this? All right.
First of all, dude, we've all been there.
We've all, you know, you got on
your head, you're going to come up.
They're like fucking Sean Connery and
one of those early James Bond's even feel
like you got to fucking Tuxedo on and
then the second you open your mouth,
you sound like fucking Arnold Horshack
and you even want to shoot yourself down
at that point. Okay. Um,
but in answer your question,
should I have told her to go
fuck herself? No, that's not. Oh,
I mean, um, I'm just, you
know, having not been there, I,
I can't,
it'd be,
it would depend on what the look
on her face was or how she looked,
you know, if, uh,
if she was just some hot girl who
didn't have a brain in our head, yeah.
Then you tell her to go fuck herself,
but this is a really cute girl and you
actually feel like, wow, I, you know,
I'd like to get to know that girl. No,
you don't tell her to go fuck herself.
It's actually in that moment when she
gives you the stink eye is when you have
to come up with something funny to say
something, something clever, something,
see show that you're not
going to quit in life.
Cause that's what I hate to say do.
But that's what you showed her.
You showed her that you have,
you have the quit DNA in your fucking
ball bag and she's not gonna want to meet
with you.
But fortunately there's plenty
other gazelles out there
on the fucking Serengeti
that you can try to run down.
You see the discovery channel,
Cheetah doesn't always
fucking run the thing down.
Sometimes he gets kicked in the face
and then it sits there feeling stupid,
especially when it realizes it's being
filmed. It's going to be on basic cable.
There's where you can,
you can actually look at a bright side.
It wasn't filmed did you? You just gotta
kind of come up with something, um,
in that moment. That's funny. And I
actually kind of thought about it,
what I would have said and I would have
choked even if I tried to come up with
something funny because in the moment
I would've felt like a Douche and I
probably would've attacked
what she did for a living,
which is the worst thing you can do and
be like, really? You know, you fucking,
you've been working here for
a year and a half, two years.
I've been seeing you making sandwiches.
You're not getting any younger
this sweetie. All right. You know,
I would have been bad. It would have been
bad. It's very easy for me, you know,
for me to sit here and tell you
what you should've done. You know,
it's kind of like, uh, you know, when you,
when you watch a football game or
something like that and once it ends and
whatever the game plan was,
didn't work out. They do.
What did they give it to Marshall
Faulk? I don't understand. Um,
it's easy to do that. So, um,
I don't know what to tell
you. Like, you know, be funny,
you got to go back there and keep
ordering sandwiches. I don't know.
That's fucking humiliating.
You might,
you might have to find a new
place to get a sandwich. Dude.
I gotta be honest with you. I don't know
how you pull yourself out of that one.
What, what did you say?
You know what? Fuck it. Oh,
this is what you do. Jake Heights is
just walking, just kind of be a dick.
You know, when she, you could just
walk up to a sunshine or something.
I don't listen to me. All my shit
just always ends up with, you know,
there's a reason I get heckled as much
as I do because I'm an asshole. Um,
but as far as like a,
what you said earlier,
cause I know there's a lot of women
pulling their fucking hair out right now.
When you say all the woman has to do
is be pretty and wait for the offers to
come in. Um, I dunno dude, if you
ever had a girlfriend, first of all,
that whole thing of looking pretty from
my standpoint and my experience takes at
least four and a half fucking hours.
And um,
and you never know that girl might've
been giving you the stink eye because
she's a really good looking girl and she,
she has a public,
she has a job where she deals with
the public. So believe it or not,
the amount of ugly fucking honest shape
dudes who actually don't have a problem
approaching beautiful
women, uh, is actually,
it's the, it's pretty high. I mean,
personally I think it's funny, but, um,
if you're a woman it's not as funny.
And I think that's something that took
me a long time to realize how like I'm
uncomfortable. That feeling can be,
you know, cause guys, thank dude,
I would love to be standing
there and women hitting on me.
But would you have to do is you've got
to see how we're physically made up.
The fact that a guy,
you know what,
what if there was this thing
that physically could beat
the shit out of you and
it wanted to enter your body?
That's the only way to try to put
yourself in the, and what if it's,
if you're not attracted to it and you
feel it getting angry when you're trying
to communicate that, you know
you're all set, you know,
and then there's the option
that if they wanted to,
they could give you a forearm shiver and
begin to execute their plan. You know?
Oh Jesus, how do I talk myself out
of this one? You know what it's like,
put it this way for all the guys listening
out there, if somebody said, hey man,
I'll give you a 10 bucks. This is
like an old joke. I just do my act.
I'll give you 10 bucks to walk over to
that birth key birthday cake can stick
your finger in it. Yeah, yeah. 10 Bucks.
Yeah. Fuck it. I'll do it. You know,
20 bucks or whatever. Just
something, you know, you'd do it.
He wouldn't think anything
about it. Whatever. Stick it in,
you take it right back out. You
know, you wouldn't give a fuck.
What if somebody said,
dude, I'll give you,
I'll give you 20 bucks to take
that cake and put it in your ass.
See what I mean? There'd be
a difference then. Then you,
you would have some questions,
you know,
where's that kicked Ben?
Are you going to tell anybody?
I usually don't do things like this.
You know, that's, that's why women,
they approached sex that way.
You know,
they've got to have rules on when they're
going to fuck you and all that to its
did that the, that example. But I
know on some level it made sense.
I'm a little jet lagged if I haven't done
that joke in a while and I got to meet
halfway through what, it didn't even
make sense to me. I'm just saying it,
you know. Did I answer your question? Um,
so this is what you gotta do. You gotta
treat a, you've got to treat women like,
uh, like I treated open mikes. Okay.
You just know you're going to bomb and
eventually you're going to get good at it.
So just keep,
you know,
make some notes what you're going to do
the next time that happens. You know,
maybe try to come up with a
couple of lines and I help women,
I hope you appreciate,
uh,
what a fucking pain in the acid is for
a guy to get laid. You know what I mean?
And that's why there's the whole,
um, stud whore double standard.
Because basically for guy to get laid,
this is what he has to go through.
This guy actually has to develop
skills to get laid. You know,
all you have to do is show up,
you know, I mean for a guy,
the brass ring is getting a
two on one. No TV credits. No,
my dad has a yacht.
You just get it from talking shit.
That is the brass ring for a guy now,
a woman, her first night of fucking,
all she'd have to do is
lay down in a pool table.
She could fuck every guy in the bar.
It's not a skill. It's gluttonous.
You know, it's gotten us, it's like
watching a fat guy eat an ice cream.
You never count on, you don't cut him
any slack. Haven't you had enough?
Um,
all right,
I'm really glad I read this podcast
because this other one was not nearly as
fucked up as this one. I don't know if
it's funny, but it's definitely fucked up.
Okay, here we go. Uh, there's
another one. I'm bill.
I'm getting laid off at the
end of the month. Naturally,
I would like to go to the dentist
before my benefits run out.
What a sad fucking state. You
know what I mean? Jesus Christ.
I really believe that people should have,
you should have some sort
of fucking healthcare.
We really need to overthrow these
fucking bankers because there's plenty of
money out there.
If those banker cunts weren't fucking
charge in the u s government interest for
its own fucking money plowing
ahead. Um, anyways, here we go.
Uh, since I did not care
much for my current dentist,
I asked my fiance for the name of hers.
All right,
so just get you caught up if you didn't
get lost in my moronic rant with no
information behind it there.
Okay. This guy's getting laid off.
He wants to get his teeth cleaned
before his health insurance runs out.
He doesn't like his dentist, so he
asked his fiance for the name of hers.
He says my,
uh,
my fiance is Vietnamese and gave me
the name of her dentist who is also
Vietnamese. Bear in mind, this is a
typical Vietnamese dentist's office.
You have a dentist and office manager
who's usually a woman over 50 and two or
three and he writes this in capital
letters, hot Asian hygienists.
I had a cleaning for one of the hygienists
who couldn't have been more than 20
years old and screamed of junior college.
This was the high point of her career
until she landed that Mrs. Degree,
I don't even know what that is.
Maybe I'm dumb. I'm so, anyways,
I'm getting my teeth cleaned.
We were flirting back and forth.
The appointment ended and we headed to
the old 50 plus office manager before I
could even a word. The old bag of
bones said, and broken, broken English.
This appointment is covered, but you can't
come back until you find another job.
Jesus Christ. Anyways, he
says, my heart hygienists,
who up until that time
was totally into me,
quickly looked at the floor and made
an immediate beeline to the nearest
unoccupied exam room.
Now,
I am not a racist,
but I was so mad.
[inaudible] a sentence like
this never ends good. Okay.
Anything that starts with I'm not racist.
Okay? But these motherfucking, anyways,
um, he says, now I am not a racist,
but I was so mad that I could've slapped
that bitch back to the Vietnamese rice
patties of 1974. Here we go. He's not
racist, everybody. How could she say that?
Especially in front of the Hottie,
who was obviously as dumb as she looked,
Jesus Christ. Dude. Uh,
when I got back to work,
I told my coworkers to story and they
implied that I was a victim of reverse
racism. If I was Asian and had eyes
that couldn't see through a key hole,
Jesus Christ, dude, she would,
she would have bit her tongue or
said something more appropriate.
What do you think? Uh, okay.
What do I think? All right.
Let me go with my first thought.
Uh, thought number one, dude,
you should not be getting married.
You should not be getting married.
Okay.
Especially because not only are
you hitting on these fucking women,
you're so fucking
like end of this shit.
Like you just told me you were engaged
and now you're dragging me into your
bullshit. And I, when people do that,
like I don't mind if a guy cheats
on his girl. I don't give a fuck.
Just don't drag me into it,
you know?
So then I got to fucking fix my face
to the next time I see your girlfriend.
Don't you hate when people do that?
You know, do what you do. What you do.
Do what you do. Do it over there.
Don't do it near me. See what you,
now you're telling me you're,
you're fucking engaged and now you're,
you're hitting on, first of all,
why are you hitting on this girl?
You know why I'll tell you why?
Because you're not done fucking and
because you're not done fucking,
you're setting yourself up, dude,
for a brutal, brutal situation.
The last thing you should
be doing is getting married.
You shouldn't even have a fucking
girlfriend right now. Okay.
And then there's a whole weird thing
where your girlfriend's Vietnamese,
you go in here,
they got all these hot Vietnamese girls
and you're saying you're not racist,
but then you're saying
fucked up shit about him.
But I will give you the benefit of the
doubt, doubt, benefit of the doubt,
because this is written.
Okay?
And the one thing that sucks about
writing shit is you lose the tone.
And a lot of times people
are trying to joke around.
So it might've been the way I read it.
So we'll leave all of that out of there.
But Dude, I'm a tell you
right now, you, you should,
the biggest fucking thing about
this is don't get married.
You're not ready to get married.
Okay?
I think you're ready to go to Vietnam
and fucking hit a single's bar.
I think you're ready to do that.
But you are not ready to be married,
so don't fucking do it.
All right? You know,
just sit down and ask
yourself, am I done? Fucking,
I guess other women, because
that's what you sign up for. And,
um, you're gonna lose half your
shit and you're going to have to,
even if you don't have a kid,
you're going to have to pay alimony.
At least that's how it works in
New York where you have to pay.
How about if you're married seven
years for three and a half years,
you have to pay alimony to a healthy
human being who really should just go out
and get a fucking job, but for some
reason they don't have to. So, um,
that's my advice. I would say
don't get married, but as far as,
were you an example of reverse
racism now? You were, uh,
you were a victim of a 50 year old woman
who is the typical front desk person at
any medical place.
They always yell out intimate information,
like information,
you know,
constantly because they're so in the
job that they stop understanding that
they're in front of the public. That
shit. He, you know, you walk in there, oh,
you know, Mr. Johnson. Oh, did you get
that ointment? How did it work out though?
Yeah. Yelled at across they, you know,
I actually worked in a dental office
and I saw people get haggling over money
all the time at the
fucking front desk and a,
I sought bother a lot of people and Uhm,
I dunno,
um, I, I don't think you are
a victim of reverse racism.
I think that the old bag of bones as you
call her a pro probably would have said
that to anybody else. She
sounds like, you know,
you kind of have to be a tough person
to work the front desk because a lot of
people try to get out of paying
their shit. So, um, your,
what you should've done was talk to
the dentist or even taken her aside and
that's what you do in that situation.
Just be like, look, you know,
I understand that I don't
have a job right now and I,
you really don't need to be yelling that.
I think you owe me an apology.
That's the way you handle it.
You know what I mean?
I wouldn't have go the reverse rate.
You gotta understand this constant
every race. So don't take it racially.
You know, if she said, hey, round die.
Why once you go get a job at Dunkin
donuts so you can afford the next fucking
payment. All right, you fat. Fuck. You
know she said something like that. Yeah,
but she kind of laid the facts
that she was rude. She was rude.
Um, that's what I would go
with on that one. Then again,
I wasn't there. All right.
What am I up to here? 39. Okay.
I gotta read this revenge story.
Then I got to get off my day cause this
is my last day in Stockholm. Sweden. Yeah.
And I want to go have a good time. All
right. Um, I called this part revenge.
The revenge stories. All right, here's
a revenge story that comes back.
I'm bringing this, this topic back.
Here's this guy's revenge story. Um,
you always hear about people
fucking up someone's car.
I actually use this guy's
car to fuck him up and no,
I didn't run him over or any
stupid shit like that. Like that.
This was more subtle and much more fun.
I was employed by a company that made
electronic equipment for computers a
number of years back and
I drove one of my, uh, uh,
I drove one of the many forklifts in the
warehouse during the regular day shift.
It was one of those warehouses,
um, where the warehouse,
he administration was
an all in one building,
which meant that everyone employed in
the company worked in the same location.
I'm the warehouse manager at the time.
My boss's boss was this short Mexican
dude who stood about five foot five and
was a fantastic shitbag asshole.
Oh,
I'm just going to let you digest that.
I never heard that vulgarity put
together that way. Fantastic.
Shitbag asshole to anyone taller than him,
which meant pretty much the entire planet
with the exception of China and maybe
one island in Indonesia,
Indonesia got on bed. Um,
he believed that leadership meant he
could be an asshole to him or whoever,
whoever damn.
Well he pleased and it pleased him a
whole fucking lot to be an asshole to me.
I won't bore you with the issue with
or your listeners with the details,
but as Napoleon complex drove his
actions more than any other reason,
this is what always happens
when I start to read them bad.
I think if I read it faster, I
will, uh, start reading it better.
Why don't I take a breath, slow down
and read the rest? Okay, here we go.
Here comes to revenge. Uh, my job would
be on the line if I outrage outright,
fuck outright faced off with this guy.
So abroad would be out of
the question and frankly,
the whole morale of the
workplace with lift a little bit.
If this shit bag was
taken down a notch or two.
So I decided to take matters in my
own hands without the use of physical
violence or property damage. Now this
here is actually a unique way to go.
All right, here we go. He said, uh,
what I did was, is I, I put up the A,
I put up his car for sale
and here's how I did it.
At the time I worked for this company,
the PT Cruiser had just come out and
this Mexican closet case went out and
bought himself one.
Maybe he thought they weren't as gay as
everyone else knew they were, but hey,
this fuck nut didn't have both oars
in the water in the first place. Um,
some months before I struck up a great
friendship with this chick who worked at
the front desk who also doubled
as a human resource assistant.
I took her out to lunch as a,
at a place of her choosing and exchange
for this shit bags, home phone number.
Here's where the fun begins.
I picked up two different local newspapers
and I took out ads for the in the
classifieds for this guy's car and arrange
to have the, have them run for a week.
The ads basically said that I had a brand
new PT cruiser for sale for less than
half the cost of the new one and I had
to leave the country soon but couldn't
take the car with me.
I also worked at odd hours and the best
time to get ahold of me would be between
the hours of one and five in the morning.
Newspapers got really lax about
their classified ads, used to be,
call the number you gave them
to make sure it wasn't bullshit.
But since the Internet and craigslist
took over, they rarely checked.
I placed the same ad and two papers on
Monday afternoon and quietly waited.
Wednesday rolls around and I can
already see the result of my handiwork.
This fucker shows up to work
without a shave. Pores themselves.
Fuck loads of coffee all day
while cowering in his office.
Like one of those baby monkeys
with the wire cage mother.
I don't know what that means.
Um,
he'd obviously been getting calls at
fuck all hours of the night and couldn't
sleep for shit. It may have cost me
a couple of bucks to get the ads up,
but to see this asshole bloodshot
and out of his head more,
more than made up for it,
that's actually pretty decent.
Um, and with that I'm going
to do overrated, underrated,
and I actually have to come in that guy
cause there was no physical violence,
didn't chop his hair off. He
didn't fuck up his car. He
just had people, uh, he had,
I like all of you also like somehow had
other people doing his dirty work for um
, I give that one in eight. Alright.
Overrated. Underrated televised poker.
Who wants to watch a group of
Asians with mullets sit at a table,
sober playing cards.
You know,
you guys are really getting good
at this writing shit, I think, uh,
with each week when you write these in,
it's making it easier for me to be funny.
Uh,
Nancy Grace,
this media whore needs to change your
fucking Tampon or get a good night's Dick
in her. All right? Child beauty pageants.
Mom never won any beauty contests,
so it's real important for her to her
fucking space that are fucking spawn does.
All right. You know what? I'm done
reading. I don't know what happened.
I can't read anymore.
These are all great.
I should read the rest of them next week.
I'm too fucking tired.
I've been stuttering over everything.
Um,
let's just end this Goddamn
podcasts abruptly. Um,
I want to thank the person who sent
me the, a ram Superbowl and, um,
I actually went on the
Internet and watched a number
of other Superbowls and uh,
I'm not gonna tell you where they are
for fear that the NFL is going to take
them down.
But they had
the,
um,
the original broadcast,
not the NFL film version.
They had the original broadcasts of
a Superbowl three and all four of the
Superbowls that the
Steelers won in the 70s.
And I gotta tell you it's a real football
education to watch those games without
like, I mean I love NFL
films style. Beautiful.
They make it in the drama and the
music and everything. But to watch the,
you know, some of them even had the
commercials. They were fucking incredible.
If you want to know where they're at,
just email me and I'll,
I'll let you know where they're at.
But um,
which is stupid cause if someone
from the NFL is listening,
did this say, send me an email,
whatever, you can find them. But anyways,
like I just, I watch
Superbowl three and, um,
you know, Joe Namath was, I like
really reminded me of Dan Marino.
Like he couldn't sack the guy.
He's totally picking up the blitz.
He had that quick release.
He was,
he was really picking them apart
and uh, but I could admit, man,
the cults just fucked themselves.
They threw three interceptions
in their own end zone,
not their own end zone and
the jets end zone. Like they,
they literally like conservatively
left like 23 points on the table in the
first. Um, and the first half alone,
and I'm not taking anything away from
the jets here because they played a
phenomenal game, but like,
uh, that Earl moral man,
he just,
he was the MVP of the NFL day year,
took over for Johnny Unitas, I
guess the guy's elbow was, uh,
was all tore up so he couldn't play. But
I mean, he had one, he had a touchdown.
It's like a three yard
pass any through it,
like Brett far be through it like 90
miles an hour to the guys outside shoulder
at the flecks off them. Easy touchdown
in. It'll shoots up in the air,
it gets picked off.
They had a flea flicker at the end of
the half and this Guy Jimmy or is wide
open jumping up and down.
He misses him and he
throws into two fucking,
I mean tactically it
wasn't double coverage,
but there was jets all around the guy.
They throw another fucking pick.
I watched three
watch Superbowl nine
which is a great game.
The first half total defensive struggle.
And then in the third quarter of Franco
Harris starts running wild and it really
wears down the front four of the
Steelers and the Steelers defense is just
fucking incredible.
And I'm something I didn't
know Terry Bradshaw was fast.
See,
I was too young to,
to know that I saw older Terry
when he couldn't run anymore.
He ran a four or five 40 and
he was a definite threat.
But,
um,
and then super bowl 10 killed me
because I was a huge cowboy fans in the,
in the 70s and watching them
kind of,
you know,
they went up 10 to nothing in the first
half and just they were playing real
loose and then they went like halfway
through the second quarter they started
playing Marty Ball.
They just do a sitting on there,
this 10 nothing lead with two
and a half quarters to go.
I fucking could not understand it.
And then all of a sudden the Steelers
just creep back into the game and next
thing you know they're down by
like, I don't know, six points.
Then they open it up again and
they fucking score touchdowns.
I was really frustrating as a cowboys fan,
but I gotta tell you,
watching those great Steelers teams was
incredible and super bowl 10 Lynn Swann
has,
I believe,
the greatest performance of any
wide receiver in Superbowl history.
And that includes Jerry Rice. He, he,
he has arguably two of the
greatest catches in NFL history.
Forget about the Superbowl.
The guy had like four catches for like
160 yards and that last past that Terry
Bradshaw's throws him is one of the
best passes I've ever seen in my life.
I'm telling you, go on, go
on the Internet, find them.
There's lot of shit up there.
There's that game where a Joe
Montana becomes a superstar.
That game where he fucking throws it to
Dwight Clark. If you're an uh, you know,
if you're a younger guy and you never
got to see those games, I'm telling you,
just go on the Internet.
You know where the fuck to go and
find them because they're, uh,
they're absolutely
incredible. And um, I dunno,
I got to watch three Superbowls
I'd never seen before.
I'd basically plus the rams.
So I watched four Superbowls.
That's what I did in Stockholm,
Sweden when I couldn't sleep. Um,
I know I'm babbling right now and this
is only interesting to a football fans.
God Damn Man, I forgot to talk
about that. Kegerator again.
I saw this story on the Internet.
I saw this TV show with this guy.
He got a Kegerator,
which I'd never heard of before.
It basically looks like a big desk,
you know, some of the bigger ones,
but it basically, it holds a keg in
there and you just have beer on tap.
And he wheeled it. He had an
in his kitchen and of course
his wife is like, honey,
it's ugly.
It Dad's in Mad Cheney thing.
[inaudible] and what does
this fucking sad sack do?
Does he say it's my kitchen til eh,
they give a shit back? No. He's like, Ooh.
And she,
you know,
they fucking wield the
thing out into the garage
and he's like, well have the garage and
I'll turn this into a man cave. Why?
You know something?
If you're a man and you've been banished
to your basement or your fucking garage,
I don't, what the fuck is wrong
with you? You know what I mean?
I don't understand that.
Why?
It's just not a partnership. I
couldn't believe it. But you know what?
It didn't really make me do as I
want to get it fucking keg of Reda.
The only reason why I'm not going to,
it's cause if I had one,
not only want it to be a
fucking raging alcoholic,
I would weigh a good two 40 I could have
blocked for Franco Harris and fucking
Superbowl nine if I had a Goddamn
kegerator. But I'm telling you, you know,
if you're one of those people who
doesn't give a fuck and you're already an
alcoholic, if you want to cut down
in some of the expenses of, you know,
we're always having to go to a store
and then everyone's trying to have an
intervention and try to help you not
be an alcoholic so they won't go to the
store anymore and you don't have to be
standing there going get me the booze.
Like that dude on intervention.
Get a fucking kegerator. It's,
it's, I'm telling you, I didn't
even know that they existed.
I just wish I was like,
you know,
1520 years younger and
those things existed.
Or maybe they did.
I had never heard of them.
But I would have had one in my apartment
back in my old bachelor fucking days
and that would have had shit on
tap because that's back then.
You remember back then your twenties
was a tail end and we could fucking eat,
drink 12 beers and eat McDonald's and
somehow wake up with a flat stomach and
barely a headache.
I swear to God,
I've never done,
uh,
I did a commercial early on in my
career long fucking time ago, my career.
Um, but now I kind of got away from it
after a while. I don't know why, but uh,
that's something I would have no
problem doing a fucking commercial for.
[inaudible] I would have no
fucking problem whatsoever
doing a commercial for a,
uh, for a Kegerator, you know, cause
that's something I would fucking use.
Oh, by the way, somebody sent
me this hilarious fucking email.
This is going to be when these
classic podcasts where I,
Sam wrapping it up and then I do another
15 minutes, where the fuck is it?
This guy sent me this hilarious email.
Remember last week when
you guys asked me about,
somebody asked me about the
bloggers and, uh, I, you know,
that, that supermodel who outed
the blogger and I basically said,
uh, that I could see, you know,
I could see both sides of it.
Where the fuck is it somebody who was
really pissed at me for a God damn it,
where is it on any level
supporting that supermodel?
I can basically paraphrase what they said,
but what they wrote was so
fucking funny though. Ah,
God damn it, I can't find
it. They basically said, uh,
sticking up for celebrities.
I knew you moving to La was a bad move.
Uh,
and it was something else about me
being a sellout and then it just said,
fuck you,
bye.
You know, and I, yeah, I just
wrote back, I was just like, okay,
have a good one. I just
thought it was funny. You know,
I just think it's funny
when people complain, uh,
I don't know that people have that thing.
If you moved to La,
like you become a phony.
It's like all that road really
proves is was I was already a phony.
And that you don't become a
phony moving out to la. You're,
you're either a phony or you're not this
phony people on the fucking east coast.
How many times you fucking cunts back
on the east coast got to get fucked over
by somebody in business or like,
dude, yeah, I'll be there. Yeah,
I'm going to pay you back.
How many fucking times of people got
to do shit like that before you realize
that there's, this cuts all
over the country. All right.
This constant la too. It's just
better whether that's, see,
that's the only difference. All
right. All right. That's it.
That's the end of the podcast.
Thank you guys for listening and
thanks to everybody in Sweden who, uh,
came out to the a rival,
a theater where I was at.
And uh,
thanks to everybody for keeping this
podcast alive with your questions and all
that type of stuff.
I hope all you guys have a good week
and I will talk to you next Monday.
All right.
The consequences.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].